Marvel's insanely popular Black Panther was
packed with amazing moments for newcomers
and comic fans alike.
But there were a few details that only the
biggest Black Panther fans truly understood.
"What do you know about Wakanda?"
Warning: spoilers ahead ...
Memorial mountain
As his father T'Chaka's appearance early in
the film showed, T'Challa's Black Panther
is just one of a long lineage of super-powered
Wakandan protectors — and while T'Challa
is the most well-known Panther, Bashenga is
one of the greatest and oldest in that line.
In the comics, Bashenga was one of the first
to don the garb and name of the Black Panther,
and the originator of both Wakanda's isolationist
leanings and the religion of the Panther God.
In the Black Panther movie, Bashenga is subtly
referenced with the name of the mountain over
which the mound of Vibranium is stored: Mt.
Bashenga.
Cutting-room costume
Concept art from Marvel's Black Panther: The
Art of the Movie showed T'Challa's smart-aleck
sister Shuri decked out in a vibranium Black
Panther suit herself, with the same gauntlet
she ended up wearing in the actual climax
of the film.
From the concept art, it seems like the Black
Panther creators were interested in at least
hinting at the comics storyline in which Shuri
takes over as the Black Panther and Queen
of Wakanda.
There may be a winking reference to that storyline
in the actual movie itself as well.
On T'Challa's challenge day, Shuri is the
one who raises her hand for the right to challenge
him for the throne of Wakanda; a moment that's
played for laughs when it's revealed that
she was just tired of wearing an uncomfortable
outfit.
A new Nakia
While every character in the movie is changed
at least slightly from their comics origins,
the character of Nakia is almost a completely
different character.
In the comics, the Dora Milaje were T'Challa's
brides-in-waiting, bodyguards that were betrothed
to the king indefinitely unless he were to
actively choose them.
Accordingly, the comics version of Nakia was
a Dora Milaje who became obsessed with T'Challa
to the point of becoming the mind-controlling
villainess Malice.
In the movie, Nakia is brave, selfless, and
T'Challa's romantic equal rather than a spurned
lovelorn teenager, so you would be forgiven
for thinking that the filmmakers kept nothing
but the name.
Still, there's a nod toward her Dora Milaje
comics roots when Nakia dons Dora Milaje armor
for the final battle.
Soldier or Wolf?
As foreshadowed in the Infinity War prequel
comics, the second post-credits sequence in
Black Panther showed Bucky in Wakanda, seemingly
cured of his brain-washing, with kids nearby
calling him "the White Wolf."
In the comics, Hunter, the White Wolf, is
Wakanda's spymaster, as well as T'Challa's
caucasian adopted brother.
Connecting one caucasian former spy in Bucky
to the White Wolf could be just a fun reference,
or it could be establishing where Bucky will
be spending his time following the conclusion
of Avengers: Infinity War.
Maybe there's a new superhero identity for
our favorite brainwashed super spy once he
hangs up the Winter Soldier duds.
Pan-African unity
When T'Challa, Nakia, and Okaye enter the
casino in South Korea to capture Klaue, it's
the start of one of the best-looking action
sequences of the movie.
But one excellent detail is kind of hidden:
Nakia is dressed in all green, Okaye in all
red, and T'Challa is wearing his characteristic
black, and together their color scheme matches
the Pan-African Flag.
Considering that one of the defining themes
of the movie is banding together beyond tribal
barriers, it's a beautiful way of depicting
that theme through three different characters
who band together to do what's right.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!